teame
日本の歯医者
第3章
部屋に入ると思わずため息が出る
アップルの製品紹介動画が作れるんじゃないかと思うぐらい
真っ白で清潔なや最新のマッサージチェアというより jal のファーストクラスの
スカイスリーパーみたいな椅子が4つ並んでいてそれぞれの右手にフードを使って
デザインしたような美しい
流線型の電気スタンドが立っている天井には待合室と同じような bravia どこ
でもまだがかかっていてその中ではゆきさんの今度はマチュピチュの階段を上っている
音量は小さく音質がはっきりしていて彼女の言葉は気候と思えば簡単に聞き取れるし
また無視しようと思えばできるので
河野邪魔にをならない部屋の左の壁には自動水栓がいくつかついているその手前には
キャスターのついた洗濯機と同じくらい大きな白い立方体の機会が2つおいては近代的
な冷蔵庫
未来の加湿器どちらにも見えるので僕はトランスフォーマーだと思うことにした
再びしゅりあ最初に目についたの
拷問道具の山田部屋の中央にを乗りつぶした三菱ミニカから織り出されたり数
みたいなものが一つあってその右手には大きな雑巾をかぶせたテーブルが置いてあり
その上には
拷問道具のフルーツバスケットやはりメス細長いのこぎりの釣り針のついたボールペン
15cm 理想な注射器
さんとかガスとかって書いてある容器ペンチペンチペンチにた位置にペン強くなって
視線を天井に向けると頑張れたか
忍耐は1管とか書いてあるポスターが貼ってある
視線を通すと
今度椅子の肘掛けの先に誰かの指の形が残っていることに気づき
一案と強烈の恐怖に襲われる
tan tan